[Música]
y yo voy a hablar del malestar en la
academia cuando digo academia me refiero
básicamente a las universidades centros
de investigación en sus sitios donde
trabajan los profesores científicos
investigadores etcétera
en la academia hay muchas cosas que no
se dicen
y de hecho cuando comentaba con algunos
compañeros que iba a hacer una charla
ted sobre este tema me dijeron que
uno directamente me dijo quizá es mejor
que no lo hagas otro me dijo te vas a
quedar sola
no va a sentar bien pero yo he pensado
que para mí lo importante es la salud y
no tanto a quién le va a sentar bien y
por eso hoy voy a hablar de esto y
aunque vaya a hablar de la academia es
muy posible que muchos de vosotros os
sintáis reconocidos en algunas de las
cosas que vaya a decir
yo soy antropóloga llevo más o menos 15
años en la academia la mitad de los
cuales los he pasado estudiando las
dimensiones sociales de la toxicidad
ambiental en el sentido de los tóxicos
químicos sintéticos que hay en el
ambiente
y resulta que no me había dado cuenta
hasta hace relativamente poco de que yo
misma estaba trabajando en un entorno
tóxico
pero no digo tóxico como metáfora esas
cosas que decimos de que hay gente que
es tóxica no nos realmente un entorno
que crea enfermedades a medio y largo
plazo y es muy curioso porque yo soy
antropóloga la mayoría de mis amigos lo
son y nosotros nos dedicamos pues a
estudiar la realidad social la
desigualdad la exclusión pero de alguna
forma no nos estamos dando cuenta de
cuál es nuestra propia situación y
aunque lo veamos bueno lo normalizamos y
no hablamos mucho de ello
y os preguntaréis bueno qué pasa en la
academia bueno lo que pasa es que mucha
gente tiene malestares emocionales o
enfermedades mentales a causa del
sistema en el que trabajan y esto es
algo que no se conoce desde fuera de la
academia y sobre lo que no hay un debate
público
es muy difícil explicarnos cómo es el
entorno académico en muy poco tiempo
pero voy a intentar como poneros unos
pequeños ejemplos de acuerdo en primer
lugar las cargas laborales la carga
laboral es tan abrumadora y excesiva que
la mayoría de mis compañeros trabajan
todos los días trabajan por la noche
trabaja en el fin de semana trabajan los
días festivos y en vacaciones no paran
jamás el otro día una compañera que por
fin se ha decidido a dejar el entorno
académico y ahora tiene un trabajo
normal me comentaba que este verano
había hecho un mes de vacaciones y
estaba maravillada porque no era capaz
de recordar cuando había sido la última
vez en su vida en su vida que había
hecho un mes de vacaciones
y de hecho yo misma no sé cuando hice un
mes de vacaciones como comprenderéis
esto es muy difícil conciliar pues con
una vida privada con una vida familiar
pero es que además estas enormes cargas
en muchos casos están muy mal pagadas
los profesores asociados que son las
personas más bajas en la escala
académica pueden llegar a cobrar entre
400 o 500 euros por trabajar
tranquilamente 10 horas al día
porque los profesores no sólo preparan
las clases dan clases y luego corrigen
sino que la academia hay que hacer toda
una serie de trabajos que hay que
hacerlos para mantenerse ahí y que nadie
te paga las ponencias en los congresos
no te las paga nadie los libros y
artículos que escribes donde lo paga
nadie todos los proyectos en los que
participa no te los paga nadie pero es
que además muchos de sus profesores no
saben si el año siguiente les van a
renovar el contrato
porque a día de hoy tres de cada cuatro
personas en cataluña tres de cada cuatro
profesores tiene contrato temporal
entonces yo he visto un montón de
profesores sobre todo los profesores
asociados que tienen que tener otros
otros trabajos para llegar a fin de mes
ya sea ser azafata camarero limpiar
pisos o lo que sea pero sabéis que es lo
peor de todo esto que normalizamos esta
situación y pensamos que si no estamos
mejor es porque no nos hemos esforzado
lo suficiente
el otro día otra amiga me había dicho
que en agosto había tenido que dejarlo
todo
para ponerse a trabajar en un proyecto
durante varios días 12 horas al día y
cuando a mí se me ocurrió decirle que es
una explotación laboral me miró muy
sorprendida y me dijo bueno no es que
claro la academia es así no
simplemente no nos damos cuenta
pero si por si esto fuera poco
la academia tiene una jerarquía muy
estricta lo cual significa que hay unas
personas que tienen poder por encima de
las otras y eso genera situaciones de
acoso situaciones de mobbing o
situaciones de abuso de poder y esto se
da y se da muchísimo
pero si quieres llegar a tener una plaza
en la academia no puedes quejarte de
nada de todo esto tienes que estar
callado
porque porque la academia es un lugar
bueno especialmente la española es un
lugar muy endogámico he visto grupos de
investigación donde cada vez que entra
una posibilidad de un trabajo remunerado
va siempre a parar a la misma persona
que es el protegido del director del
grupo o la protegida de la directora da
igual y el resto de personas no tienen
una oportunidad
pero es que pasa lo mismo con las plazas
de profesor el sistema está hecho para
que sean los departamentos de cada
universidad quienes eligen a qué
personas contratan entonces muchas veces
no tiene que ver con sus méritos
laborales sino con quién son sus
padrinos y sus padrinos son obviamente
esas personas para las que ha tenido que
trabajar gratis o de forma precaria
durante muchísimos años entonces te
encuentras en la academia a un montón de
gente de 40 y de 50 años que todavía no
tienen una plaza estable porque llevan
años y años y años encadenando
precariedad laboral
pero es que si al final tienes una plaza
en la academia no creáis que la
situación mejora al revés la academia es
el entorno hiper competitivo y solo unas
cuantas personas pueden mantenerse ahí
y como lo hacen pues buscando tus
propias subvenciones buscando
rentabilidad tus proyectos compitiendo
por publicar en las mejores revistas
cubriendo tus propios costes en una
palabra funcionando como si fueras una
empresa o un autónomo esto es lo que a
día de hoy la universidad valoran sus
trabajadores que sean económicamente
competitivos
claro esto hace que tengas que competir
con tus compañeros de trabajo
y eso genera unos entornos laborales que
no son precisamente agradables entonces
en los departamentos universitarios ves
cómo se generan grupos peleas rencillas
se acaban durando años y años
y en todo este sistema quien lo tiene
peor
pues los de siempre las mujeres las
personas étnicamente distintas las
personas con diversidad funcional pero
sobre todo las personas de clase más
baja porque mucha gente no puede
permitirse mantenerse en ese sistema y
tienen que abandonar
y aunque nos pensamos que vivimos en un
país de igualdad de oportunidades esto
no es así o al menos no es así en este
entorno
porque solamente unos cuantos pueden
mantenerse ahí
claro estaréis pensando que esto pasa
también en otras profesiones
especialmente en profesiones creativas o
de alto rendimiento y es verdad porque
en realidad es un problema social más
amplio pero a mí me parece especialmente
grave que esto pase en un sistema de
enseñanza superior un sistema que muchas
veces es público y que hace que sus
trabajadores enfermen
de qué enfermedades estamos hablando
bueno cuando consultan los estudios que
hablan básicamente de tres que son el
estrés la ansiedad y el síndrome de
'burnout' síndrome de 'burnout' es lo
que se conoce como estar quemado o demás
el problema es que los estudios que hay
son dispersos no son comparables entre
sí y sobre todo no hay estudios
longitudinales lo cual es muy indicativo
ya de la poca importancia que se le da a
este tema pero estudio site y de hecho
hay muchísimos y hay en países tan
distintos como norteamérica inglaterra
españa a francia méxico o japón pakistán
lo cual significa que aunque hay
diferencias culturales entre distintas
sociedades esto es algo que está pasando
en la academia en muchísimos sitios
por este motivo observando mi entorno y
observándome también a mí misma que
también he tenido síntomas de estrés
hace un par de años empecé un proyecto
con una amiga en el que bueno hacemos
difusión sobre estos temas hacemos
talleres etcétera entonces para que os
hagáis una idea en los talleres que
hacemos le pedimos a las personas que
nos definan cómo les hace sentir su
trabajo o qué es lo que les genera su
trabajo
y para que veáis el cien por cien de las
personas que participan en nuestros
talleres nos dicen cosas como estas
sentimiento de culpa insomnio
alcoholismo drogadicción alopecia las
migrañas gastritis vista cansada
trastornos alimentarios automedicación
miedo con frente al futuro miedo
constante al futuro
os podéis imaginar lo que es trabajar en
un entorno así
el otro día tengo una amiga que se
levantó estaba desayunando se desmayó y
perdió el conocimiento
y su marido la encontró una hora más
tarde pero es que lo grave es que esto
no es la primera vez que lo veo a mí
misma me han pasado cosas similares pero
todos estos malestares se consideran uno
problemáticos o sea se sabe que están
ahí pero bueno no son un problema
como dijo mi otra amiga es que la
academia es así
el filósofo francés michel foco hablaba
de un concepto que es el concepto de
vídeo poder
que habla un poco de cómo se estructura
el poder en nuestros días lo que él
decía bueno es un concepto más complejo
pero una de las cosas que decía es que
en muchos casos el poder no es necesario
ejercerlo por la fuerza sino que ya está
instaurado dentro de nosotros mismos en
cada uno de los trabajadores de manera
que no necesitamos que nadie nos
controle porque somos nosotros mismos
los que nos autoexigimos nos auto
controlamos los auto regulamos etcétera
y esto es exactamente lo que pasa en el
entorno académico estamos tan
obsesionados con la productividad que
nos sentimos mal cuando un domingo vamos
a la playa
nos parece absolutamente normal trabajar
todos los días a todas horas queremos
producir más publicar más tener más
proyectos
no salto explotamos pero también
explotamos a la gente que hay a nuestro
alrededor
yo he llegado a recibir un whatsapp un
día 1 de enero donde ponía algo así como
hay que hacer esto hay que acabar ese
trabajo
lo que no ponía era hola o feliz año o
perdona que te moleste en un día festivo
y esto pasa constantemente porque no nos
damos cuenta de que no sólo nos
explotamos a nosotros mismos sino que
explotamos a la gente que tenemos
alrededor y nos respetamos ni su vida
privada ni su tiempo propio esto no le
pasa a todo el mundo pero si le pasa a
muchísima gente entonces porque no
hablamos de ello
porque básicamente admitir que tienes un
malestar o una enfermedad mental puede
significar que no te tengan en cuenta
para un próximo proyecto para un próximo
contrato o para un ascenso es
básicamente un estigma
y de hecho se habla en el entorno
académico pero se habla en privado
pero yo creo que es necesario ampliar
este debate y empezar a pensar en
medidas concretas es necesario ser
conscientes de la situación en la que
estamos es necesario cuidarnos a
nosotros y también cuidar a los demás y
es necesario un cambio de cultura si no
queremos vivir enfermos infelices pero
sobre todo es necesario dejar de pensar
que todo esto que os he contado es
normal
porque la verdad es que esto no puede
ser normal
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]